as we get into the second half of the
1930s we seen an increasingly
aggressive nazi germany in 1935
they publicly announced their intent to
re-arm
their military the reason why this is
significant
is not that they were all of a sudden
building their military they in fact
were doing this as soon as they had
taken power in 1933
but now they felt confident enough to
publicly state their intention which is
another way of publicly
of publicly stating that they could care
less about the treaty of versailles
which had said that germany was limited
to a hundred thousand
soldier military then we get into 1936
1936 you might remember another term of
the treaty of versailles
was that germany was not allowed to
occupy the rhineland this area
in yellow right over here and then that
was actually reaffirmed in 1925 by the
treaties of lucarno
where germany itself agreed to not
occupy the rhineland
but by 1936 hitler decides to ignore all
of those
and occupies the rhineland occupies the
rhineland but once again
the allies the french are not so happy
about this but
yet but the uk in particular once again
not
not super happy about this but they
decide that this is not
reason to potentially start another war
over so they really don't push back on
germany
then we get into 1938
1938 and german aggression really goes
into
full gear in march in march
of 1938 you have a
a a coup d'etat orchestrated by the
nazis
in austria that really overthrows
the the austrian government and allows
the germans to
unify the two countries so you have the
germans
come into austria really a bloodless
takeover and there is uh there there was
already popular support for the nazis in
austria there was a nazi party in
austria
there had been popular sentiment for for
many years amongst many austrians to
possibly be unified
with the germans austria is
fundamentally a german-speaking
nation and so in march this actually
happens this ancelus
or unification and if you remember that
was also another forbidden term of the
treaty of versailles so now the germans
are pretty much ignoring the treaty of
versailles
and the treaty of saint-germain which
was the equivalent of the treaty of
versailles
but with the austrians so you have a
unification of
germany and austria then
as we get into late 1938
in september in particular hitler and
the germa and the nazis
are interested in in in bringing
the german-speaking populations of
czechoslovakia
under german control and this region
right over here in magenta this is where
you have you have large populations of
german speakers
these regions are collectively referred
to as the sudetenland
suedetin sudetenland
and really just continuing the policy of
not wanting to rock the boat with
germany you have france great britain
and italy agreeing and italy wasn't was
an ally of
of the germans but france and great
britain in particular are not interested
in rocking the boat with the germans and
so in september of 1938
they signed the munich agreement the
munich agreement
which did not actually where they
actually did not consult
the czechoslovakian government where
they allowed germany to
take over this region right over here
the sudan land
and that frankly with the germans taking
over this the significant part of the
the population
of czechoslovakia a significant part of
the
industrial capacity of czechoslovakia
this eventually leads to
early 1939 early 1939
where all of what we would now consider
the czech republic
the the this area right over here all
over
this becomes a protectorate of germany
so they they call it the the
protectorate of
bohemia and moravia so bohemia
and moravia go to germany
and moravia and so this is
1939. so as as we get into early 1939
you see this repeated pattern over the
last four years
nazi germany ignoring the treaty of
versailles by rearming by occupying the
rhineland
by unifying with austria now they're
expanding their territory
they they are actively allowed to take
over the german-speaking areas of
czechoslovakia under the munich
agreement
and eventually they are able to take
over bohemian moravia all of kind of
the what we would currently call the
czech republic
and this general pattern of german
aggression followed by
the other powers in europe essentially
allowing it to happen in particular
great britain allowing it to happen
has been referred to as a policy of
appeasement obviously the word
appeasement means if you there's someone
who's angry about something and you just
don't want to make them any angrier you
just let them do whatever they want
this is essentially what was happening
over here and in hindsight it might be
easy to say hey look they were allowing
germany to take over more and more to
become more and more aggressive
which made it more and more confident
and this would eventually lead to
world war ii but at the time you do have
to remember
there the the the everyone still had a
very strong memory of what had happened
in world war one
and no one was interested in starting
another pan-europe war and so
even in in hindsight it's easy to to
uh to say that the the british in
particular neville chamberlain who was
the prime minister from 1937 on
were weak and allowed german the hitler
to gain confidence which
eventually allowed to which eventually
led to the nazi invasion of poland at
the end of
in the fall of 1939 but
it's easier it's easy to say that in
hindsight but what we see
as we get into 1939 is a aggressive
germany a germany that's not being
checked by the other powers of europe
and this is what eventually leads to
september
of 1939 where actually the germans and
the
soviets agree to partition poland into
their own spheres of influences
which allows germany to invade poland
in early september 1939 which is
you could kind of say the straw that
broke the camel's back and is the
beginning
of so poland invasion invasion of poland
which is the beginning of world war
ii